there's definitely signs that we're at a
very precarious moment right now right
the government of canada is now
calling these emergency powers and you
know that once the government goes with
emergency powers it doesn't give those
uh powers away quite easily uh so jordan
peterson who of course is from canada
okay jordan peterson was a professor at
the university of toronto for many many
years he was born in western canada i
mean he's a true son of canada and then
became the most influential you know
public intellectual on the globe uh he
gave a little video did about a three
minute video
right before trudeau announced the
emergency powers and he talked about
this precarious moment we're in because
you know when you start making getting
somewhere right as the truckers did they
did it right they started getting
somewhere so some of the restrictions
were being pulled back
well then some people start walking away
maybe the radicals double down the
government reaction et cetera et cetera
so jordan put out sort of a basic
warning for where we're at at the moment
and again i just want to reiterate this
was done before a few hours before
trudeau came out with his emergency
power speech
i've been asked to say a few words to
the truckers in ottawa
and so i've given that some careful
consideration
all you protesters
you've accomplished an awful lot already
you know the conservative leadership has
crumbled and
aaron o'toole's been replaced by someone
who is giving a fair bit of voice to
your concerns
you now have a voice in the house of
commons all the people you represent
have a voice in the house of commons
you have four provinces that have moved
quite precipitously
in the direction that the protest was
hoping for starting to lift mass
mandates on something approximating as
reasonable a timeline as might be
expected under the circumstances i'd
like to commend all of you for your
diligence and
and work on
accomplishing what you have accomplished
under under trying conditions and also
for keeping your heads in a way that's
actually being
a
model for the entire world the fact that
you've been able to remain peaceful you
haven't taken the bait you haven't
responded with violence to
quite remarkable
denigration and provocation that's
a sign of tremendous discipline and care
it's going to get more difficult to
maintain as this goes along
so i hope that you're all in this
position to
allow
a sufficient victory to be sufficient
to move forward without rancor
to
be
grateful for the effect that you've
already had in the support that you've
received
and to
move forward to a normative peace and
the re-establishment of our
country's economy and our
psychological and social well-being
so
that's pretty much all i have to say at
this point
thank you
i mean first off there's just nobody
better you know careful with his words
sober
optimistic realistic
clear all of the stuff i am
jordan if you're watching today i am
truly honored to call you a friend and
someone that let me uh join the ride for
a year and a half when we toured
together
i wanted to bring up one specific point
that he brought there and again this was
before justin trudeau ramped this all up
he said it's going to get more difficult
you have to allow for a sufficient
victory and that's what was happening
until trudeau ramped everything up right
there were premiers in uh alberta and
some of the other provinces who were
saying we played the videos on the show
here you saw it over the last couple
days that we're saying we're going to
scale back on some of this stuff we hear
you we know you're frustrated they were
even saying we know you guys have done
this peacefully and you've protested
properly
we're gonna you know reverse course on
some of this crazy lockdown stuff and
the mandate stuff so they were getting
their victory and then what jordan was
saying to them was now that you've
gotten some measure of victory you have
to be careful uh because you know some
of you the the same more marginal people
involved are going to go away but the
people who really believe in the cause
they're going to continue in essence
that's where things can get
you know radicalized etc etc so there
was a really interesting moment there
and it's and that is an important piece
of this right regardless of what side
you're on it's like when you get some
victories you have to know you got a
victory and you have to be gracious for
that so i think that was happening
it's actually that's not that i think it
was happening it was happening we know
they were getting victories and then the
question was well how do you take that
victory and move forward now the problem
is that just as some victories were
happening just as
say a true healing was on the horizon
like oh we protested properly in a
western democracy the government heard
us and they're going to scale back on
the stuff that we're protesting then
trudeau just stepped in it because about
two hours after jordan posted that video
trudeau says he needs emergency powers
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades
and occupations and he's going to arrest
protesters and they are going to find
people out on the streets and they are
going to come after your bank accounts
and they're going to go after the
crowdfunders etc etc so now trudeau is
the one who just poured gasoline on the
fire so i i will actually message i'll
text jordan right after this and see if
maybe he'll put one of those messages up
directly to justin trudeau and stare
directly in the camera and say justin
trudeau well you almost had victory to
some degree not victory for justin
trudeau because he wants ultimate power
that's that's what sits beneath these
people but justin trudeau had an off
ramp there really was a way that we
weren't going to be in the situation we
were in today that's what jordan was
laying out there like take your victory
like sit with it for a little while guys
go go i got something and it was good
and and let's go home for a little bit
or or let's keep the pressure on but
like let's acknowledge that there was a
chance that was justin trudeau's
off-ramp they were giving it to him the
other premiers by saying we're going to
scale back some of this stuff but then
he just went all in and that's what they
do with everything that's what the left
and progressives and whatever remains of
the liberal structure that has been
decimated
over the last decade or whatever it is
they double down on everything and that
was always the danger i mean watch my
videos literally guys from six years ago
why was i screaming about all of this as
someone on the left when i was a bernie
supporter saying we can't call everybody
racist we can't call them all bigots and
homophobes and transphobes and all of
those things because once you do that
they're they're the ultimate enemy
they're the ultimate evil and you never
have to look in the mirror and that's
what trudeau has gone with how can
trudeau possibly put an olive branch out
to the homophobes and the racists and
the bigots
i guess he could do it while he's in
blackface if he has any sense of irony
that might be one way to do it